southern hills hospital got its first  batch of covid19 vaccines this morning  it plans to vaccinate everybody in the  hospital over the next three days  healthcare workers at sunrise hospital  are also getting the covid19 vaccine  from pfizer today  sunrise held an emergency or rather an  exercise yesterday  just to make sure distribution goes  smoothly  and we know from the moment that vaccine  hits our loading dock  to the direction it's taking into the  refrigerator we have the ultra  cold filtration here at sunrise we're  very fortunate to be that  we know the timing it takes to thought  we know how to distribute it  we have all of our members in line yes  we have  thought through every individual step  st rose dominican hospitals are also  getting ready for vaccination here's  some video the hospitals provided to us  today  of the vaccines arriving